at the same time
[ __ ]
i think it's really good
okay
oh
okay
two minute warning
so
maybe i just
you
you
okay
uh
hmm
hello everyone it's another historic day
here at the white house
and i have with me ambassador rick
grinnell national security advisor
robert o'brien and senior advisor jared
kushner
to talk to you about the history that
was made here at the white house today
and then they'll take a few of your
questions
thank you kaylee uh again it was a
uh a great morning uh in the oval office
uh with
president trump president vucic and
prime minister hoti
we brought together through the hard
work of
great diplomats primarily led by uh rick
grinnell
acting at the president's direction
serbia and kosovo
and they've normalized their economic
relations this is a
the serbia kosovo conflict has gone on
for decades
they've been stuck unable to move
forward for many many years
and the president some time ago decided
that we tried we needed to try something
creative try something new
break the deadlock and bring uh try to
to move forward with the peace process
with serbian kosovo uh
to have the prime minister of kosovo and
the president of serbia
together in the oval office with
something uh given the history of those
two countries
and given the history of the united
states with respect to serbia
uh and the conflict in the balkans is
something that is is quite remarkable
uh and to have this happen uh just in
the uh
the shadow a few days after uh jared and
i were on a
the the flight from uh ben gurion
airport to abu dhabi international
airport
uh the first commercial flight between
israel and a gulf arab state
it shows the sort of momentum that's
coming one of the side benefits of the
normalization of economic ties
between serbia and kosovo was a
the establishment of diplomatic
relations between kosovo a
majority muslim state and the state of
israel
this is now the second time in in less
than a month
that israel has made peace with and has
normalized its ties
with a majority muslim country it's
again it's another
really signal accomplishment of
president trump
the fact that this has happened
on the heels of uh a a peace agreement
uh with the taliban in afghanistan uh
that it's happened
uh in response uh on the heels of of
last year negotiating a piece
uh a ceasefire between the kurds and the
turks
uh you're seeing a pattern here of the
president
uh being a true peacemaker uh
and and there's been plenty of criticism
of the administration
but what's been interesting to me is as
the president has undertaken these
historic
uh initiatives uh and brought together a
team to perform
and deliver these accomplishments uh
others have uh
have even tried to take credit i was
just watching the vice president without
making a political comment the vice
president was welcoming
uh these moves today but the these
things could only
happen under a trump administration and
under the president's uh leadership
peace through strength foreign policy
and national security policy he put the
pieces
in place uh and now we're reaping the uh
uh the peace dividend and it's it's
happened to the balkans it's happened in
the middle east
uh and we have more to come i'll leave
some of that to to uh
senior advisor kushner to address in a
moment so uh
with those opening comments i want to
turn the uh
the time over to uh the special envoy
for serbian kosovo the presidential
envoy for
serbia kosovo ambassador rick grinnell
uh he'll have a few comments and then
we'll make ourselves available for some
questions
after uh rick and jared address you
thank you very much
thanks robert um i know there's a lot of
reporters who have worked a long time
in your industry and for any reporter
that has
been working for more than 10 years you
will know this story
there was a terrible war and this story
has been lingering for decades
and so i really want to appeal to you
all as
journalists to dig deep on this story
this is
one of those good news stories that
i'm not asking you to do anything but
look at the facts
and look at really what's been happening
here we've been working
very hard on this agreement for a long
time
we had three agreements last year
that went largely unnoticed by
washington reporters
and i just really have to say i think
it's a shame when we
when we talk a lot about symbolism and
we don't dig deep
on these stories that last 21 years
what we've been able to accomplish here
by pushing the two
parties together is truly historic
the the way that this came about is that
the politics
were stuck everybody knows that we've
been fighting and talking about the same
thing for decades they have been
fighting about the same symbolism
words verbs adjectives
it's been a nightmare and what president
trump said to me
was they're fighting politically about
everything
why don't we give it a try to do
something different and creative
why not try to do economics first and
let the politics
fall follow the economics
that proved to actually be a formula
that they were eager for
no one had been talking to them about
this we have an establishment
foreign policy team in washington dc
that literally keeps pounding the same
meetings and issues over and over
i'm telling you that the only way that
this agreement could have happened is
from an
outsider all of the insiders in
washington said
you're not talking about recognition
you're not talking about
this symbolic word and what we tried to
do
is ignore that and from an outsider
perspective
go in and dig deep i i ask you to look
at this agreement
and see all of the details
that have been hard fought negotiated
that will move
both economies and the entire region
forward
this is economic normalization it's a
first step
i think the europeans are going to be
very happy
we've been on the phone a couple of
times with the national security advisor
in germany
the national security advisor in france
to be to brief them
we briefed them on the strategy and we
are briefing them again today
on the details of this agreement
this is something that i feel very
strongly about
it will make americans safer it'll make
american companies
more prosperous this is a region that's
been largely shut out because of a
perceived
conflict whether or not there's been a
conflict there has been a perceived
conflict european businesses and
american businesses
largely have refused to go in and grow
in the in these areas
now we will be able to open this up
whether it's in
energy water construction of roads
railways mines these are all industries
that are going to be opened up to
european
and hopefully american businesses to go
in and help
the people create an industry which
means
creating jobs in the in the region but
also u.s
jobs jobs for americans and american
companies
the last thing i'll say before we turn
it over to jared
the people of serbia and the people of
kosovo
are ecstatic about this agreement
and are very thankful that there was an
outside administration
to look at this situation and not
do the typical political thing if we
would have done the typical political
thing and listened to all of the
really smart people at ngos and think
tanks here in washington
dc we would not have this agreement take
just a quick look at the criticism and
the lead up to this
of what we should have been talking
about and what we weren't talking about
it's
all been squarely in the same old
political dialogue
that was stuck and i'm really thankful
that president trump challenged us to
say
think differently think from an
outsider's perspective
and that was the key to the whole thing
so i really urge you to look at the
details and see
and talk to the the leaders in kosovo
and serbia
ask them how this came about ask them
how the process went and i think you'll
see that
this outsider perspective of doing
things
differently is what worked
thank you ambassador grinnell an
incredible job working through this
historic agreement and ambassador
o'brien
this is just another chapter that this
administration has been able to write
towards making the world a safer and
more peaceful place
president trump when he ran for politics
was not a politician he sees things
uh in a through a prism that not a lot
of politicians
uh look through which is how can i truly
do things that will make
people's lives better make people find
common interests and opportunities
and figure out ways to resolve conflicts
that quite frankly
politicians have allowed to go on for
far too long
today's breakthrough really is historic
and we have had so many historic things
this week that
we shouldn't be minimizing the
significance of
all the different things that happened i
started the week with ambassador o'brien
in jerusalem where we met with the prime
minister and then took the first ever
flight commercial flight from israel to
united arab emirates we broke that
barrier which brought a lot of hope to
the middle east and for
the last years i've been listening to a
lot of people tell
uh us and the administration all of the
things we were doing wrong while we were
looking at this the wrong way
and what the president's done is he's
reversed now 20 years of bad foreign
policy in the middle east where we've
allowed our country to get trapped in
a lot of these wars that quite frankly
uh
you know don't do much for our country
we have to make sure that we're keeping
our country safe and we need to figure
out how we can get people in the middle
east
and in europe to get along so that we
can spend our resources and our treasure
on building up our countries and
building up our cities and helping our
citizens and
what you've seen through president
trump's first three and a half years is
he's
ended he's trying to end a lot of these
endless wars he's making peace
agreements he's bringing people together
and he's bringing our troops back home
to america while
figuring out how to get along with
different countries and reducing the
foreign threats that we have
second this week obviously we're in
saudi arabia and then saudi arabia
announced
the historic opening of their airspace
which again brings people in the middle
east closer together
and then yesterday bahrain announced the
same thing that they'll be opening up
their airspace
which again will allow flights and
better commerce and interaction between
peoples
to happen the middle east in a much
quicker way today we announced another
normalization with israel which
quite frankly a lot of the divide
between
the the anti-semitism that we have in
the world the terrorism we have in the
world
comes from the notion that people are
divided and
and leaders will exploit divisions and
religious differences to try and
keep people divided to cause conflict
often to maintain power for themselves
that they mask in an ideological way
this breakthrough again brings people
closer and shows people in the world
that
anything is possible if we push for it
and again
fundamentally president trump believes
that no matter who you are no matter
where you're from no matter what country
you're in
uh all people want the same thing which
is they want the opportunity to live
freely live better lives have economic
opportunity and live in peace and
today again is another historic step
forward that politicians have spoken
about for for decades but haven't been
able to deliver on
and it's another uh victory for this
administration and really for the world
and so i want to
give my congratulations to the people of
serbia and the people of kosovo
and and to the people of europe and also
to the people of israel who will
you know reap tremendous benefits from
this agreement so thank you
ambassador brian um the us government
determined that russians are seeking to
quote
undermine faith in the electoral process
by spreading disinformation
about the accuracy of voter data for
expanded vote by mail
and president trump has also said that
state's voter data is not accurate
and he's telling people to not trust
that their mailing ballots are counted
so is the president helping russia
spread disinformation
well i think what we have with when it
comes to elections and what the
intelligence community has made very
clear is that
first you have china which has the most
massive
program to influence the united states
politically you have iran and you have
russia
these are all three adversary countries
uh that are seeking to disrupt our
elections
some of them prefer biden some people
say some of them
prefer the president my position is it
doesn't matter what these countries want
that any country that attempts to to
interfere with free and fair elections
the united states
has to be stopped we've taken
unprecedented action the president has
taken unprecedented
precedent action uh in funding uh the uh
the hardening of our election
infrastructure whether it's cyber
uh or otherwise uh obviously there are
tremendous concerns about mail-in
ballots uh
in the news every night there seems to
be another picture of uh some apartment
building in some city with thousands of
ballots stacked up in the foyer of the
apartment building and that sort of
thing
uh so i think there are concerns about
mail-in ballots uh i think that
that those concerns are very different
than being concerned about foreign
adversaries
trying to influence our elections and
we've made a red line we've made it very
clear to the to the chinese to the
russians the iranians
and others that uh uh that haven't been
publicly disclosed
that anyone who tries to attempt to
anyone that attempts to interfere
with american elections i will face uh
extraordinary consequences
but russia said russia mr o'brien a
question on serbia in kosovo then i just
have a follow-up on that
um in terms of the the two parties
agreeing to freeze the recognition
and de-recognition campaigns how long
will that last and how important is it
to the administration
that serbia recognized kosovo's
independence so i think it's a year
freeze
so that that and that the idea of that
freeze is to give the parties time
uh to negotiate some of the political
issues that are between them and our
european partners there's a european
uh special envoy uh uh mr lycheck
who's involved in those uh those talks
we're gonna be supporting the europeans
and those political talks
there are a lot of issues involved there
whether it's eu membership or
mutual recognition so so there are a
number of issues that the the serbs and
kosovars will address
will support the europeans as they
address those issues what we wanted to
do in this agreement was create some
breathing space
for the parties to engage in those
without the back and forth campaign of
recognition and derecognition
what's striking though is that as part
of that deal
uh kosovo was allowed and
i shouldn't say a lot that kosovo did
make the decision as a muslim majority
country to
normalize its relations with israel uh
to recognize israel
and to to establish an embassy in
jerusalem uh in the capital of uh
of israel and uh and uh we appreciate
the fact that the uh
uh the the sir that serves not taking a
position on that so
although we have d where we're gonna
have a suspension of the d recognition
campaign and the recognition campaign
it's two sides of the same coin
for the next year uh we were able to
achieve uh
with the courage and bravery of the of
the leaders of president buchich and
prime minister hauti and
and prime minister netanyahu we were
able to see this you know very
remarkable breakthrough
again the second time in in now a month
it took i think 40 years to have two
muslim majority countries recognize
israel now we've had two muslim majority
countries recognize israel
uh in uh in less than a month so it's a
remarkable
achievement in the context of this this
overall freeze that will give the party
space to negotiate a deal
just to follow up on what ben was asking
you attorney general barr said earlier
this week
that he feels china is being more
aggressive in meddling in the election
than russia is
do you agree with that assessment
and then i just want to follow up on
that and i've also got a question about
israel
um can you just characterize at this
point uh the extent
and the level to which both china russia
and other foreign countries are right
now trying to spread disinformation
about the 2020 campaign
yeah look it it's it's hard to know uh
you know what impact they can have or
how they're spreading things i think
some of our tech companies are doing a
good job in
in trying to police uh uh whether it's
facebook or twitter others are trying to
police things in a way that they didn't
before
our intelligence community is doing a
good job in trying to track these things
uh dhs department of homeland security
uh with with increased funding from this
administration
uh is doing a good job in hardening our
infrastructure to make sure that uh
whether it's cyber infrastructure or or
physical infrastructure to make sure
that we're not susceptible to having our
the the the choice that the american
people make on election day change by
some foreign party
uh there's always gonna be propaganda
there's always efforts to
influence us and again we know that the
chinese have taken that the most active
role but
uh but the russians and the iranians and
and other countries are involved in well
as well so we're going to keep
monitoring it and we're going to do
everything we can to protect uh the
sanctity of our election that's the
foundation of our democracy that what's
that's what makes us america
and we're just not going to tolerate uh
you know these other countries trying to
get involved in our elections
in the oval office
sure quick follow-up on israel yes i
want to make sure everyone gets a chance
the president had said
in the oval office earlier that there
are other arab countries that are also
interested in following in the uae's
footsteps can you talk about where we're
at on that process what countries are
interested in turn that over to senior
vice president jared who's just returned
from the region
and uh and maybe i'll give you some some
background there
thank you not going to give as much
background but bottom line is is when we
did the
israel united arab emirates deal that
caught a lot of people by surprise
because
of the diplomacy that we were able to do
was to keep things private
obviously we had some great discussions
in the region uh and
uh and we are hopeful that more people
will want to move forward i think a lot
of the countries are
uh quite envious of the opportunities
that will now be available to the united
to the united arab emirates
in terms of mutual investments mutual
tourism
uh investing in technology uh security
partnerships so
uh we're seeing that that peace
agreement actually starting to really
pick up a lot of momentum and the
delegations that
uh traveled with ambassador o'brien and
myself had a very very fruitful
discussions i think both sides were
surprised to see the eagerness of the
other side to move forward
and the level of getting uh agreements
adjudicated and completed is happening
much quicker than people thought
um other countries again see uh the
benefits of having a middle east and
that's that's united and if you look at
what president trump uh did on his first
foreign trip he went to saudi arabia and
he outlined
very clearly what his strategy was going
to be what he saw as the challenges and
again if you just go from that snapshot
to now three and a half years later
you have the middle east where isis is
defeated iran has been significantly
rolled back
uh the proxies that they've been funding
that have been spreading terror and
instability throughout the region
uh are are much shorter on cash than
they were before
he's brought the different sides
together and you know one story that i
think doesn't get enough attention
is the fact that uh in the last election
a lot of what we were talking about
was the uh the spread of of extremism
through the internet and then also the
funding of terror
groups and president trump on that first
trip set up two different
organizations in saudi arabia one was
the counter-terror finance
organization that unified a lot of the
middle eastern systems with our treasury
department and we got more transparency
than we've ever had
that's significantly reduced the amount
of funding that's gone to terror groups
over the last three and a half years
the next thing we set up was the counter
extremism center which has been fighting
the ideological battle
online and has been making really a
tremendous amount of progress
towards uh towards reducing uh the
misinformation that's been used to
pervert a lot of the youth so we're
seeing a lot of progress in the middle
east
and i think a lot of countries at this
point see it see it as an inevitability
that they're going to have normal
relations with israel and that in order
for people to live better lives it's not
dissimilar to
serbia and kosovo where you know their
leaders are coming together to realize
that while there are differences
uh you know human beings want to get
together they want to have better lives
and opportunity
and the more that the leaders in the
middle east you know put all differences
behind
they're creating a new opportunity for a
new middle east and a bright future
where people can live securely practice
whatever religion they they choose
respect each other and have economic
opportunity which is
uh critical towards people you know
seeing a pathway to a better life
thank you this is actually your journey
with two questions i'll just combine
them to make this easier
with the election coming up in two
months i'm curious as to how you feel
about what you've accomplished so far
but whether or not you feel pressure to
get more done
before november and secondly because i
know you
would have been part of these
conversations with the time i do want to
ask you about that atlantic report that
we saw today
and how in a 2018 planning meeting for a
military parade
the president reportedly said he didn't
want amputees there
he said nobody wants to see that have
any of you but particularly you ever
heard the president talk like that the
answer is no look at what i find in
washington is
is strange is sometimes you'll have a
couple unnamed sources and the media
treats that as a panacea
and then you'll have you know 10 people
on the record saying it didn't happen
and you give no credence to that that
does not represent the way that i've
seen the president
uh conduct himself he has tremendous
respect for the military for our
veterans he's
uh you know again the media tries to
ascribe a different way but you have to
look at his actions and
i think his actions have been incredible
towards supporting the military
strengthening the military and
strengthening
our veterans but with regards to your
question on timing
look deals uh deals happen when deals
are ready and and i do think that
you know you can't just come in wave a
magic wand and make impossible deals
happen right people
you know describe peace in the middle
east as something that's so it's it's
less a deal than more of a saying for
what is impossible
and it's taken a lot of building blocks
that had to be moved a lot of
untraditional moves when the president
moved the embassy to jerusalem when he
recognized the goal on heights when he
got out of the iran deal when we did our
economic conference in bahrain
it's probably 50 decisions that the
president's made that allowed him to
create a different course and each one
along the way you've had people like the
magazine you mentioned before
criticizing his foreign policy saying it
wasn't strategic it didn't have a plan
but again you know he's not a
traditional washington person and the
traditional washington people
have a track record of creating those
wars that we have sent our soldiers to
that have
you know led to a lot of them getting
you know killed or or hurt
and president trump's been ending those
wars and bringing the soldiers back home
and so
uh i would say deals happen when deals
are ready and the deal that you saw last
week
had nothing to do with the election it
had everything to do with the fact that
you know it's it's it's it's it's time
for the president to start harvesting
some of the accomplishments that he
spent years building
the foundation in order to achieve and
what i would say too is that
if you look at you know the world
foreign policy is is a big chess game
and you have a lot of pieces all over
the board in different places and the
president's been masterful with the way
that he's
built different relationships taken some
pieces off the board created different
issues other places and i think that he
set the board up
very very well now to have uh continued
successes in the years ahead so
obviously the voters will decide
uh whether they give president trump
four more years but if they do
uh given four more years i think you'll
see that iran is in a much weaker
position than they were four years ago
uh north korea we've we've had obviously
a much better situation they had four
years ago
uh venezuela's in a different situation
the middle east went from a place that
you know again when president trump got
in
libya was a mess syria was a mess yemen
was a mess
all of our allies felt alienated iraq
was a mess and you see a much different
middle east today
than we had three and a half years ago
and that's not an accident that's
because president trump has had
a good strategy and he's worked very
hard
to to manifest that so now we're
starting to see some of the fruits from
his labor
uh but i do believe that we'll see even
more and more of that
as time goes on so we're set up for more
successes hopefully in the weeks ahead
the months ahead
but definitely in the years ahead to
take president trump's america first
foreign policy where he's making
trade deals for the first time that are
endorsed by our workers and our labor
unions that are bringing jobs back home
uh he's representing our farmers he's
representing our ranchers he's
representing our manufacturers
um and he's also ending these endless
wars
and figuring out how to bring our
soldiers home and and fighting the
threats from overseas so that americans
can prosper here at home
let me just weigh in for one second on
on your
uh last question about the atlantic
article uh which i i thought was really
a
a a sad article for for any magazine uh
to have published and while i wasn't in
the meeting
uh that's that's described there i've
worked for this president for two and a
half years first as a hostage ongoing
for last year's national security
advisor
in both those jobs i've had to uh to
meet extensively with the president
on uh on military issues whether it's a
hostage rescue mission or
uh how we're gonna deploy our troops uh
around the world
uh and i look i've had my current job i
have the sad duty of having to call him
sometimes in the middle of the night if
we lose
uh soldier sailor airman or marine uh in
a in combat which which hasn't
fortunately hasn't happened since
february or in a training accident we've
had some of those recently
uh and i can tell you how hard those
calls are for me to make
but also for the president to receive
i've spent a bunch of time with the
president
on numerous trips to dover and uh and
seeing how he's been with the families
of our fallen heroes for those dignified
transfers
and i can tell you that's the toughest
job any president has is to go up to
dover
and and bring our fallen heroes home and
uh and
and mourn with their families and grieve
with their families and comfort their
families
uh and i think if you if you talked to
any of them uh who had been there uh
uh for the transfers when the
president's been there i i've seen him
uh uh send me to dover uh i've got you
know when he couldn't go because of
scheduling issues or him being overseas
uh and asking me to represent them there
i've been with them at walter reeve
where we've seen our wounded heroes
and and the interaction between the
president and our wounded
uh heroes at walter reed is something
that's that's pretty
incredible to see i can tell you when we
discuss
options and sometimes we have to discuss
military options for some of the foreign
policy and national security issues that
we face
the president will ask me you know is
there a way that we can do this without
sending u.s soldiers
or sailors or marines or airmen into
harm's way uh
if we have to send them into harm's rate
way and and it's going to be a tough
situation
i like the baghdadi rate for example how
do we make sure we protect them
uh to the maximum extent available and
if that means putting three or four
levels of air power over them
uh it means doing that uh and the
president is
is unstinting in in what he's willing to
to provide to our our troops
he's he's funded the military so we can
give them every tool necessary
to accomplish our missions and come home
safely uh
you know so i think if you talk to any
any of us who work at the nfc any of us
have worn the uniform before that's
keith kellogg or
matt ponder or myself or mark milley
over at the pentagon or
or those that spend a lot of time with
the president especially when military
matters are discussed when
when our our uh current military
personnel our troops are discussed our
veterans are discussed
uh you're not going to find you know
anybody who's more sympathetic
uh to their situation the president
united states so i don't believe a word
of what was in the atlantic article
because i've had two and a half years
of working side by side with the
president i've never seen anything like
that
and and i thought it was uh it was
pretty disappointing that some magazine
would
write that ambassador brian on the topic
of service members first thanks to all
three of you for hosting this is the us
going to respond to russia's recent
aggression
toward u.s forces in syria yeah so so
one of the things that we do
uh uh constantly is we respond to uh
to forces we were you know operational
security opsec is critical to us
anywhere our
soldiers sailors airmen and marines
operate whether it's in the maritime
environment
on land in the air and uh and we do see
uh
aggressive behavior from the russians uh
we've seen that uh with some of the
intercepts
that we've seen we've seen it over the
past couple of years and how they've
interacted with our naval vessels
uh we've seen it in the screen on the
current uh uh
situation with the uh with the patrols
uh coming across
each other uh but i can tell you that uh
you know
american forces have rules of engagement
designed to protect them
uh to allow them to defend themselves uh
you know there was a an unfortunate
incident when
russians purportedly russian mercenaries
attempted to overrun one of our forward
operating bases in syria
uh a couple of years ago that didn't end
too well for them
and because again president trump gave
our
our soldiers in that instance the
ability to defend themselves
uh you know with with you know air power
with
with
long-range fires uh with their own
resources so
uh you know we're gonna make sure that
everywhere we we operate whether it's
uh operating a place that's in close
proximity to the russians to to any
other adversary
uh the men and women in uniform will be
able to defend themselves and protect
themselves has that warning been
communicated to the
to the russian government yeah it's been
communicated to him very clearly
you were by the president uh it's been
communicated to at the
appropriate level and to whom was it in
russia specifically i'm not going to get
into those details
because we want to have those channels
open but they've received a very strong
message
thank you thanks ambassador brian i
wanted to follow with a couple on china
i'm wondering what specifically you're
seeing from china that makes you
believe that they have a bigger or
harder working electoral interference
operation than russia or other countries
and then based on that or
you know the litany of other concerns
that you've described about china
if you could kind of tell us the status
of efforts
by the administration to either go after
chinese firms or imports or
diplomatic uh issues with china yeah so
let me talk about the china situation
overall so so probably the the biggest
failure
uh of of american foreign policy over
the past 40 years is how we've dealt
with china
there was this mantra uh that that
somehow as china became richer
uh as we turned a blind eye to chinese
malign activity whether it's stealing
our ip or engaging unfair
trade practices or or bullying its
neighbors
if we just turned about bullying its own
people at tiananmen square if we would
turn the other cheek turn a blind eye
that china would become richer as it
became more as it became richer and the
middle class and china grew
they'd become more like us and we always
wanted we want to believe that
that everyone wants to become like us
that they become more western more
democratic
uh in fact all the opposite occurred
china's human rights violations have
gotten worse and worse over the years
whether it's the uyghurs or
uh religious minorities or their
neighbors the
people who enjoyed democracy in hong
kong until just recently
uh the bullying of taiwan uh so so we've
seen very malign chinese activity the
theft of intellectual property has
gotten so bad that christopher wray the
director of the fbi
uh recently called it the greatest
wealth transfer in human history was a
theft by the chinese
of our intellectual property now that's
not just an
abstract concept okay that that's sweat
equity that's american innovators that's
that's people that are putting their
put their whole life into dreams people
have invented things in their garages
people who built companies who
have done everything they can to to to
create uh
an idea and turn an idea into reality
and then what happens
that idea gets stolen by china and it's
not just that they've lost the economic
value of of their innovation
or of their of their method of doing
business the chinese have taken it
sometimes using slave labor but using
cheaper labor often manufacture
products that compete at a lower price
and then put the original person who
invented the
the uh the technology out of business
and and then kill the industry for the
united states and
whole industries go to china whole
manufacturing plants go to china
i mean it's been really astounding chris
frey said that also said that the fbi is
opening a new espionage case against the
chinese
every 10 hours the scope of chinese
activity against the united states is
relentless it's we've never seen
anything like it there's nothing like
this in the cold war with the soviets
uh so so this president president trump
stood up to the chinese for the first
time in 40 years he put tariffs on the
chinese
uh we had a trade uh a phase one trade
deal that partially addressed some of
the unfair trade practices
and was a huge step in the right
direction but as soon as that was signed
we ended up with the the was the
president calls it the china plague or
the covid
uh outbreak here uh which made that you
know somewhat irrelevant
because of the tremendous losses we
suffered again because the chinese
wouldn't share the virus
samples with us early wouldn't let cdc
doctors come into china early to
investigate
wouldn't let who doctors come into china
to investigate
wouldn't restrict travel from china to
overseas especially to europe
when they were restricting travel within
china uh so
so again you know you know uh
you know well look when it comes to the
to the election
everything that they're doing across the
board whether it's political influence
through the confucius institutes
uh whether it's it's them trying to
influence uh
business leaders by saying if you don't
support us in the u.s
your companies won't have opportunities
in china and convey that to your
governors and
convey that to your political leaders uh
the massive i'm not gonna go into all
the intelligence but but the the the
massive
activities of the chinese in the cyber
realm uh it's really an extraordinary
thing that we're facing
and again this is the first president
that stood up to the chinese
i hope he's not gonna be the last
president who stands up to the chinese
uh and as difficult as the problem is
let me tell you i'm confident in the
united states of america i believe at
the end of the day
we're going to prevail we've got to
peace through strength foreign policy
finally
uh that we've been missing for for some
time now we're investing in our defense
we're taking strong action on the
diplomatic front against the chinese
we're taking strong action on the trade
front
uh we're protecting our intellectual
property uh we're not gonna you know
we we've called out the communist
chinese party
uh we're taking strong action and have
massive sanctions uh
on the chinese for the first time
because of their treatment the uyghurs
or their treatment of democrats in hong
kong uh i think at the end of the day
uh our allies are gonna follow us which
you've seen happening with 5g and huawei
uh and we're seeing many many countries
including our closest allies turning
away from the chinese turning away from
huawei
and going with trusted providers on on
5g
so i think at the end of the day america
is going to prevail i think president
trump's vision
of free markets and free women and free
men
is an attractive message not just to our
allies but but to even people within
china so
you know i'm confident in the future but
i'll tell you this is a challenge it's a
heck of a challenge
uh but but i'm convinced that under
president trump's leadership the
american people are up to the challenge
raise your hand and then otherwise i'm
going to turn things over to you
right here mr thank you actually
i appreciate you calling on me but this
question made more maybe more
appropriate for rick or jared in the
sense that they deal with both policy
and politics
and if i may as you know in 1992
president george h.w bush ran for
reelection largely
on his foreign policy successes and
americans largely
rejected him for a second term what
makes you think
based upon the announcement that you
need today regarding
kosovo and serbia the announcement that
came out just a few weeks ago regarding
israel
and the uae that americans are more
focused on foreign policy
that they care about foreign policy and
that these announcements mean something
to
them look i think that these
announcements are about
president trump keeping his promise to
take on the hard fights to end the
endless wars and to bring his troops
home and to keep americans safe and i
think that that's what it shows
it also shows that president trump has a
track record of continuing
uh to get things done you know he he
really has a great track record
for success our economy was going great
until the
until obviously the virus hit we we did
a dip people predicted we'd be down to
25
unemployment and that we wouldn't get
the single digits unemployment until
early next year
and obviously we had a great jobs report
that came out today and we have more
coming so
the answer is is people will vote for
whoever they think will make their lives
better
uh president trump just happens to be
doing a great job at foreign policy
delivering a lot of wins that
uh had previously plagued the last
administrations and quite frankly the
last administrations that had a lot of
mistakes and a lot of adventurism that
you know got us into these uh tough
situations in these regions and today's
agreement and all the success this week
just shows again that president trump is
uh is is getting things done and and
keeping americans safe and keeping his
promise the american people so
but he's not running on his foreign
policy he's running on his track record
as
uh the president who built the greatest
economy um
in in our country and and somebody's
going to keep americans safe and
continue to get things done for him
another question for both of us uh
ambassador grinnell
uh clearly uh you were effective here as
the special envoy uh to these talks
between serbia and kosovo
but i wanted to ask you about another
initiative you led uh last year you
kicked off the trump administration push
to decriminalize homosexuals i'm going
to just talk about customs
i don't know if you can find it on a map
but this is atrocious
i have to tell you guys you might be too
young to understand
what this issue is about maybe the older
journalists should step
up and say this is a big deal this is a
big issue i
i'm astounded at what happens in
washington d.c and especially
in this room i i got to tell you get
substantive maybe it's too
complicated of an issue for you all
right respectfully this is the first
time we've had the opportunity to speak
with these individuals okay but today
let's take a little time and talk about
this 21-year
issue peter i mean 21 years shoot we're
getting the same
questions that are all politics i don't
you guys don't understand what's
happening outside of washington dc
people aren't listening to you anymore
it it's really a crisis in journalism
and i think it's because people are too
young to understand issues like kosovo
and serbia
how about a substantive question i don't
think any of us came here for a lecture
about our questioning
i would like to ask you the question i
would like to ask you is
is it accurate to say that it's full
economic normalization
there was some ambiguity as to whether
that is what the deal is about
and what do you what do you mean by full
well
that's the question for you i don't know
it's a question for you
what's your definition of full this is
economic normalization
for whatever the two parties could bring
together a whole bunch on rail
a whole bunch on water a whole bunch on
a whole
different industries working towards
economic normalization is that fair
no i think it's incredible economic
normalization
air rail motor
opening borders uh a whole bunch of
industries so again i don't know what's
missing
and i defer to you to say what
associates what's outside of of economic
normalization that's not included here
you tell me
genuinely asking so that we can write
our stories accurately can we say that
they i would say
you know a few months ago when they
pulled down the tariffs to today what is
the substance have you ever had to eat
right now you haven't put
it out it's up um a whole bunch
a whole bunch has changed since the
dropping of the tariffs
the tariffs were the political sticking
point of why
we couldn't have the parties come
together the serb side was not going to
even start negotiations
when there's a 100 percent tariff from
the coast of ours
the substantive thing to change today
like what is there's a whole bunch of
stuff that changed today in terms of
economic development
in terms of identification for
uh even some political problems that are
going to be resolved
um i i would really refer you to
to look at the entire agreement one
sticking point that
has been for a long time
something that the two sides couldn't
agree on was the recognition of diplomas
if you were trained as a nurse in serbia
and your degree was from a serbian
university you couldn't get a job in
kotovo
because you weren't qualified you didn't
have the proper certificate
that now with this agreement goes away i
think that's economic normalization for
people who have certificates and dental
hygiene in pharmacies
uh pharmaceutical experts there are a
whole bunch of people who could not
work simply because they didn't have the
proper
career credentials and this
agreement completely will recognize all
diplomas
from universities from either side i'll
give you one more example
american companies were telling us they
were pulling out like
rental car companies because if you
rented a car
in kosovo you couldn't drive over the
border
you couldn't leave so people who were
wanting to
go for tourist purposes or to visit the
region or to try to do business
uh deals they couldn't actually leave
with that rental car and so we had
american businesses beginning to pull
back to say just doesn't make sense
uh the europeans were complaining just
as much there was a perceived conflict
and i think what we have now with
this historic air agreement rail
agreement motor agreement
all of the things that they've committed
to implement will create
normalized commerce and that is
something that has never been tried
we have been stuck on literally verbs
and symbolism in terms of negotiations
on the politics
and we're gonna try something new the
president of serbia said
uh today to local reporters that um
i can read the quote we have made a
bilateral agreement with the us
not kosovo can you clarify what that
means
yeah well first of all i don't i would
never try to clarify what president
buchich means when he's talking to the
serbian press
uh i can tell you what he said inside
the oval office
which was that this was a historic
agreement
to normalize the region he talked about
the mini shenzhen zone
which is now going to be an economic
region so
i think it might have been lost in
translation a little bit
but make no mistake that the agreement
that they signed is definitely
an agreement to expand commerce in the
region
and there's no question that when you
look at
diplomas for instance or the one-year
freeze
on recognition and de-recognition um
on even the rail agreement there's a
there's a depart u.s department of
energy
study uh that will take place on a lake
that is largely in kosovo
a portion is in serbia we're going to do
a feasibility study to figure out
what kind of jobs can be created in
around the water
there's no question that that's a shared
uh
agreement did they sign an agreement
with each other or did they sign an
agreement with the united states
they signed an agreement to work with
each other
they didn't they did not sign with the
united states we're not a signature
president trump signed something we we
watched him
yeah correct what did he design
he signed a how would you describe it a
basically a letter acknowledging that
they are going to work together and do
this agreement maybe it's easiest to ask
this way
can you just lay out very specifically
what each gentleman signed today
what was that they both signed
agreements to work together to normalize
their
economic and commerce relationships are
not the same right
they are 99.9 the same but of course
there's
there's one there's one point that's
different at the very bottom
which is that serbia is going to
move its embassy by july of next year
that's on the serbian agreement and for
kosovo
their last point everything is identical
to the last point the last point
for kosovo is that they have a mutual
recognition with israel
and and the infamous item 10 they were
mentioning yesterday
that's taken out right i mean that's
what president
was saying today yeah first of all it's
wrong to say that that was item 10
none of these were uh numbered so i
don't know where that that came from
when we were negotiating there were a
whole bunch of issues on the table uh
a whole a lot of things were changed and
edited as you can imagine
in negotiations that this does um for
someone to
leak a partial sentence and pretend like
this was the
entire agreement i think is typical
politics
but nothing was numbered certainly
wasn't number 10
and nothing is agreed to until
everything is agreed to
so something leaked out in terms of
negotiation
but it was partial and i think it was
highlighted in a way that that gave a
false impression
i just asked one more thing uh maybe
it's semantics but we
have been having this dilemma for quite
a while now when you say shenzhen do you
think
shenzhen is in china's uh province or
sheng dan like in europe because we
couldn't figure it out so
just just to clarify what did president
trump say
so we're not a party to the agreement
and i guess this is super important to
remember is that
we didn't come and there's a whole bunch
of conspiracy theories out there about
what we were coming to the table with
we were not forcing the two parties to
do anything this was a real
chance for the two parties to talk we
didn't have any grand scheme
we didn't have any absolute demands
we certainly didn't have i don't even
want to say the word
of of what some conspiracy theorists say
about
past agreements with land would
was never discussed in my presence
what the two parties did was agree
to move forward economically what
president trump signed
is as a witness to say this is a great
agreement
and the united states is happy for it
right
yeah the eu has tried and failed for the
past 10 years to accomplish what your
team
is celebrating today um how confident
candidly
all of you how confident are you that
leadership in the eu
leadership around the world is looking
at this as a template for success
or is it going to take a whole
generation of new leadership in order to
kind of
study what you have accomplished here
and in the middle east so so i i really
have to own
this to say i think we all failed
for the last 10 years i wouldn't just
put this on the europeans
i would say that it's the establishment
foreign policy thinking
that has failed both in in
europe and here berlin paris london
washington dc um
we had great support from the french and
and from the germans
to try this new way of economic
development and let's also be very clear
the europeans have a lot of economic
development that they can do
and they will do they're the the team is
meeting on monday in brussels
and so there's a whole new aspect to
this um
and and let me also just say on on the
question on this item 10
um one of the reasons why we were
willing to not talk about it here
was because it's on the agenda monday in
europe
and we're trying to team this with the
europeans to say what can you do what
can we do to kind of move this forward
so on monday that issue will be dealt
with
very much in detail
in brussels and so i felt confident that
we could kind of let
and work with the europeans on this
issue and so that's why it was
it was taken out but at the end of the
day
we need the europeans we need them to to
help on this issue
um we will help them but their calculus
on the political side is a little bit
different because both kosovo and serbia
want eu membership and so they're
looking at this very long path
of how to get into the eu we're
supportive
of our european partners on their
process
but we are not making any demands we're
not a member of the eu
so we don't have a seat at that table
but we certainly will help in any way
possible
but that is a separate political process
i think
that that also complicates it because of
the
uh eu membership rules and regulations
and processes
thank you guys very much
so the president is bringing back the
hottest economy in modern history
today's job numbers are proof
there were 1.4 million jobs added in
august speeding expectations
unemployment fell by one point
eight percent also beating expectations
now nearly 50 percent of job losses
since march have been reversed a clear
v-shaped recovery also i want to address
what is quite clearly fake news the
story in the atlantic
has been categorically debunked by
eyewitnesses and contemporaneous
documents
the atlantic claims quote when president
trump cancelled a visit to the ain marn
american cemetery near paris in 2018
he blamed duran for the last minute
decision according to the atlantic
saying the helicopter couldn't fly
and that secret service wouldn't drive
him there neither claim was true
says the atlantic that has been debunked
behind me you will see a email from one
of the president's military aides that
clearly reads
we are a bad weather call for today's
lift
the atlantic reporting is based on four
cowardly anonymous sources who probably
do not even
exist meanwhile within hours
10 sources 10 when on the record
debunking these lies
eight with first-hand knowledge stating
on the record
one common truth that this story is
false
it never happened adding to the eights
that were
previously counted i'm bringing you two
new ones one is from derek lyons steph
sacra staff secretary and counselor to
the president who says this
i was with the president the morning
after the scheduled visit
he was extremely disappointed that
arrangements could not be made to get
him to the site
and that the trip had been canceled i
have worked for the president for his
entire administration
one of my responsibilities is working
with him on the many letters he signs to
the families of our nation's fallen
heroes
in all my time at the white house derek
writes i have
never heard him utter a disparaging
remark of any kind about our troops
in my view he holds the brave men and
women of our armed forces in the highest
regard
i also bring to you today another quote
from a
former and member member of this
administration dan walsh
deputy chief of staff former deputy
chief of staff who is also a retired
military officer i got off the phone
with dan just before coming out here and
he wanted me to share with you all i can
attest to the fact that there was a bad
weather call in france and that the
helicopters
were unable to safely make the flight
overall the president's support
and respect for our american troops past
and present
is unquestionable and dan recounted to
me several
events he went on with the president
like a world war
ii uh veteran who flew with the
president on the helicopter in normandy
uh visits the president had with our
wounded warriors
special ops teams who came to the oval
office
um including the team that got al-bag
daddy and they brought along
conan the dog as well he met with
families at the army navy game he does
this routinely
i mean at the world series when he got
an opportunity to go watch the nationals
he brought veterans with him and i can
tell you from what i've seen for this
from this president i have heard him
describe
his visits to walter reed and in detail
and
the angst he has had and the compassion
he has had and
the hurt he has had viewing these
warriors who have um
been been absolutely injured in the line
of duty and are courageous heroes and
i've heard him recount
how meaningful those visits are i've
also seen him just a day before this
article came up um
talk about there was rain and lightning
popping around and he said i want to go
out there and i want to talk to
our world war ii veterans this is
america's greatest generation and the
president
um holds them in the highest of regards
so why would a publication
abandon all journalistic integrity and
publish this story
it's because the liberal activists at
the atlantic are uninterested in the
truth and they are only
interested in peddling conspiracy laden
propaganda because here is the one truth
no one and i mean no one
loves and cares for our service men and
women as much as president donald j
trump thank you
i don't get it what was in it for them
was it the president
it is thanks brother
you